hello folks welcome to
rational science directly from frankfurt
germany
and what do we do here we're we're the
only site on the internet that does
physics
what does everybody else do
well they do mathematical physics
uh which ain't physics
and it's the
even the dissonance to mathematics what
is it they have this notion that science
is about doing experiments
about uh doing equations measuring you
know calculating doing equations
and
describing mathematically
making predictions
observations repeating the experiment et
cetera et cetera
none of that
according to this site has anything to
do with science
okay
so we have a paradigm shift that we're
proposing since the beginning of the
century
and that is that science is something
else
science is rational explanations
okay science is not about mathematical
descriptions which is the only thing
that mathematics can do describe
mathematics has no power to explain
so it's not surprising that the
mathematician since the 17th century
so-called
scientific revolution i call it the
unscientific revolution
uh have proposed
uh that you know science is about
describing not about explaining
because they could not explain anything
they could not explain a single
phenomenon
and what did we end up today
well we ended up
using that method right we ended up with
what we have today irrational
explanations in quantum mechanics and
irrational explanations in general
relativity
okay what are these irrational
explanations well i'll just give you a
couple examples so that
you know you can
i think you can see real quick that
they're irrational
uh particle can be at two places at once
according to quantum mechanics
and then uh general relativity you know
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
because there's this unimaginable
four-dimensional
concept
called space-time
that is warped and prevents our earth
our beloved blue planet earth from
flying out of the solar system
and then i have this singularity known
as a black hole a mathematical
singularity that twirls stars around
itself real live stars
you know swung around by a mathematical
concept
and then we have you know
big bang creationism
tactions particles that are so fast
faster than light that they come back
from the future
what is all that nonsense that's physics
so yeah no wonder they said well no
physics is just the math the equations
because we can sink our teeth into that
yeah but those are descriptions
and like you go to quora where i write
quite a bit
and
which is a site that answers questions
and so on
and what do you find everybody wants to
know mechanisms they want to know how
gravity works they want to know how
light works what is light uh they want
to know how electricity work how how
magnetism works
people want to know how things work they
want to know how mother nature father
universe uh god the devil whoever you
pray to
does all these magical things out there
okay
and uh you don't find explanations you
don't find mechanisms physical
mechanisms what you find is equations
that are probably true you know in other
words uh they describe the visible
objects
how they behave
but they tell you nothing about the
invisible
things
that mediate those transactions
and that's when the mathematicians
that's why we call it mathematics
they introduce something more than magic
what they do they introduce concepts
and convert those mathematical concepts
into physical objects they reify them so
you have words like energy
and energy is a concept
it's defined but as the capacity as we
will find out also today right
and uh they transferred the capacity
it's like transferring love or
intelligence i'm gonna transfer love
so they transfer the capacity
mass what is mass well it's uh some kind
of measurement right
and they're gonna move the mass they're
going to move the measurement
and so on so
we have irrational explanations
and so yeah we criticize all that in
this site
and that takes us
to where we
have been what we have been doing for
the last few months which is we start
out with extinction
and i got into extinction the subject of
extinction because of relativity because
all the mathematical physicists out
there physicists being with quotation
uh they believe we're going to live
forever
you know we're going to get out of the
planet
at least if you ask the people at nasa
right they're investigating all this
stuff
out there how to travel to mars and from
there on maybe to the nearest star you
know the alpha centauri system out there
and yeah and then we're probably going
to expand to the galaxy throughout the
galaxy
and have all these level one level two
and level three uh civilizations
what the hell is all that
i'm saying we're about to become extinct
here folks
we're at the end of the line and these
people are talking about the future
there ain't no future
and
so we start out with uh extinction and
now a fellow yesterday pointed out
pointed me into the direction of an
article that was written by
he's an editor of what is it of nature
and he wrote the article in
scientific america
and his name is
g or or
i think that's how he pronounces his
name g or like in mcgee
maybe d i'm gonna call him g like g whiz
okay so
this is the fellow
and he wrote it i wrote in scientific
american humans are doomed to go extinct
yes
he got that one right no doubt but we're
about to go extinct
and he says the following uh a pallet
well this is his title he's a
paleontologist evolutionary biologist
and editor at nature
and he wrote this piece for scientific
american and right off the bat he says
habitat degradation low genetic
variation declining fertility are
setting homo sapiens up for collapse
which is what i've been saying the last
20 years okay i've written extensively
about that i've got videos on that
um
you know the whole works uh he it's
almost like he took all this from my
book uh why god doesn't exist okay
and so i applaud the man he he got those
right and he goes into a little more
detail here he says the following
and again matches everything i've been
saying he starts out with what we call
in rational sciences statement of the
facts
okay these are not facts they are his
personal beliefs or his personal
assumptions on which he's going to base
his theory they're known as statements
of the facts under rational science in
other words they are not facts they are
just
what he's going to start his theory with
okay and so he says humans have been in
breeding for over 300 000 years and have
ended up with little genetic diversity
by the way these are my summaries of his
arguments these are not verbal
uh
textual things that he said uh and we
both see eye to eye on this yeah we've
been around for 300 000 years and we
ended up with little genetic diversity
and i'm saying that's because of
inbreeding okay
uh next
main point uh since the 1960s population
has more than doubled whereas sperm
quality has declined possibly due to
pollution and stress
other than the pollution and stress we
see eye to eye on that issue as well but
the birth rate has declined in great
measure due to women's emancipation and
global population will reach its zenith
in mid-century
okay and uh here you see uh
these are the growth rate population
growth rates
okay
and what they tell us is that yeah if we
if everything stays the way it is until
now
uh we're going to end up with um you
know with uh
a zenith in other words a maximum
population sometime around this uh
century and and
the numbers now point to around
mid-century
okay
and um
okay and let me
go with his conclusions then
uh well uh let me finish that other one
there economic growth is unsustainable
totally in agreement where we disagree
is in this last statement because
resources are finite
that's just going to be his argument
okay
and yeah there we have a big problem it
has nothing to do with the finiteness of
resources okay
and so his conclusions are something
like this the cause of extinction is
usually a delayed reaction to habitat
loss
absolutely not
and habitat becomes degraded there are
few
fewer resources to go around and again
i'm going to say absolutely not
okay so we disagree
completely on that our theories diverge
at this point okay
let me get this out of here
give me a second here
okay so uh what's my argument on this
well i'm saying it's got nothing to do
with resources
are there finite resources on the planet
yes absolutely
uh if population keeps increasing will
be
will we consume those research resources
will be exhaust will we exhaust them
we don't even need to grow i mean if we
leave the population stable it is as it
is now eight billion people right
uh and we just consume consume consume
consume and leave even the population
more or less you know fixed or constant
we're going to eventually
get rid of
most of the resources on the planet but
a lot of that has to do with a person i
essentially dislike
that i don't agree with just about
anything but i'll have to agree with
this on him and that's milton friedman
and his notion against all malthusians
who said you know population doubles
every uh 25 years and we're going to
outstrip resources here i'll have to
agree with mr friedman and and that is
the chicago school of economics and what
he said is that yeah it's a question of
money
you know if you want to draw water out
of the center of the sahara desert
it's an issue of money
someone will do it for the right amount
of money they'll go out to the sahara
desert and they'll draw water from the
center of the earth if necessary
resources is a question of money but
yeah there are finite resources i'm not
sure you can take uh friedman's argument
to an extreme there are there is a point
at which you outstrip resources
but my point here is that that's going
to be way beyond
the extinction of man man's extinction
will become will come much sooner than
the stripping of resources
same with climate change climate change
this climate change yeah it's always
changed i don't know a single day in the
history of life on earth where
climate has not changed
and did that cause the extinction of
species or anything like that
and i'm saying absolutely not
climate changes and
you know it's very slow
uh climate is is a very slow process and
so we don't have to worry about all
these
nuts out there who talk about climate
change
because it's got nothing to do with
nothing absolutely anything it has no
bearing on anything does climate change
yeah it changes but it works so slowly
that human extinction will beat climate
change when it becomes important you
know and relevant it would beat them by
a mile human extinction is right around
the corner
okay is it because of resources is it
because of climate is it because of
disease is it because of an asteroid is
going to hit us on the head is it going
to be because some volcano is going to
erupt is it going to be because some
supernova is going to wipe us out like
in the ordovician
no absolutely not uh
mass extinctions never occurred because
of catastrophic accidents
it's uh again the religion of
mathematics okay that penetrated um
paleontology specifically with mr louise
louise alvarez and
he he made it famous this asteroid
theory right uh 1980s
and even before him you had uh you know
people who talked about that all the way
to george couvier
in the uh late 18th century they already
thought about you know some
extraterrestrial impact this was nothing
new the only thing that louis proposed
or came up with is what is important to
the mathematicians and not the science
and that's proof
evidence
persuasion conversion
you know recruiting
that's what it was all about because
mathematicians uh emphasize
recruiting proof evidence
and proof of evidence have nothing has
nothing to do with science has to do
with religion with persuading you to
change your mind to change your way of
thinking that's what a prosecutor does
science is not like law
you don't go to the jury and try to
persuade him and convince him we do
anyways because it's human nature but
that portion of your presentation has to
be
seen as
religion
science is objective we explain a theory
so that you understand it
once you understand it that's the end of
science what continues is religion
belief opinion
voting you know raising your hand
that's religion and so mathematicians
you know they emphasize proof and
evidence and that was what
the asteroid theory was all about
and so yeah um
here's the big picture of how mass
extinctions happen and i always
emphasize that you got to do extinction
101 before you do extinction 102.
what is extinction 102 it's human
extinction
and first before you do human extinction
you have to know something about
extinction you have to go to
kindergarten extinction uh class and
learn something about extinction
you can't just jump to human extension
say oh and i know how man's going to
become extinct or how he will not become
extinct now first you got to go to
extinction
101 and find out what that's all about
and so here's extinction 101 from my
point of view okay this is the objective
theory of how uh extinctions happen mass
extinctions okay i'm going to talk only
about mass extinctions okay and here
a wood picture is worth a thousand words
okay what you have is different types of
plants that govern millions of years
uh in these different epochs or ages or
whatever
and uh so you have primarily there we'll
see the seed firms in the day
days of the permian and the triassic you
have the age of gymnosperm gymnosperms
or um you can call them conifers in the
jurassic and cretaceous and today we
live in the age of angiosperms we're the
age of mammals and you can see what
happened here if you were standing at
the beginning of the
cambrian 542 million years ago well you
would look forward and what you would
see is that when the ferns disappeared
well the you know the mammal like
reptiles disappeared and when the
uh
especially the cycads because jurassic
was known as the age of cycads but when
the conifers disappeared the dinosaurs
disappeared
and guess what's going to happen when
the
angiosperms disappear especially the
angiosperms we eat
because we don't eat all angiosperms
okay well then we disappear okay so the
mass extinctions are caused by
the disappearance of a food chain and so
here we have the definitions okay
and the first one is the the one on the
top that's going to be a not a mass
extinction but a background extinction
you look up the word uh background
extension the term background extension
you won't find a definition
what you'll find is the background
extinction rate
what is right
mathematics
again they talk about math they want to
put math at all
into science at all
points we don't need the rate i need to
know why one species disappeared all by
itself
for example the neanderthals you know
how did they disappear well we have the
brains at the max planck institute they
say because they married with us they
interbred with us
boy that would have probably saved
humans you know we would have had more
genetic diversity but no we never had
sex with the neanderthals and i've
written extensively about that uh no
they died because their population
pyramid overturned and for what this uh
gentleman uh g uh henry g i think um
proposed and that's that we've been to
we've been inbreeding
not interbreeding but inbreeding and the
dandruff neanderthals were inbreeding
for thousands of years and at the end
they lost their genetic diversity and
above all their population pyramid
overturned
and that's the mechanism of a background
extinction what is a background
extinction not the raid but a background
extension it's the disappearance of one
species how one this species disappears
all by itself
but see the mathematicians talk about
all those
species that die in the background
and so they they're concerned about the
rate but they never
focus on the mechanism why does a
species disappear all by itself what
happened to it
and so again they don't do physics they
do math they call it the rate and that's
why we don't have a
definition for the term background
extinction
and then uh how about a mass extinction
which is what we participate in humans
okay and again it's the overturning of
the ecological pyramid what happens is a
mass extinction is with disappearance of
a food chain
it has something to do with food
that's the way mother nature does mass
extinctions okay
and what happens is you have the many
chasing the few
okay
you have
uh many herbivores
going after
less and less food their islands are
shrinking because the type of food that
they eat okay is disappearing
okay in the case of the
for example mammal-like reptiles of the
permian
and even the triassic the archosaurs
well what happened they ate ferns
specifically seed firms okay and their
foods not only were had were dying
because of thousands and really millions
of years of inbreeding
those those uh plants finally ended up
you know uh
being all clones
and they were dying at the end lots of
species were dying and it's different
when you have a radiation at the
beginning of an epoch where you have
these like the ferns you know first they
radiated there were many species and
quantities of these
uh plants and you had all these animals
that were you know
squatting niches they say oh i'm going
to take this one the other guy said i'm
going to take that one and they grew in
relation to the varieties and numbers of
seed ferns
but what happens towards the end well
after millions of years they lose their
genetic diversity you have a population
pyramid overturned of the plants
and now the animals they don't know it
but they're multiplying and here the
plants are shrinking on them in other
words the the uh
jungles and forests are becoming uh i
call it the shrinking island you know
because the islands their islands of uh
food are shrinking while they are
expanding and at some point there is a
crisis and that's when they die
parallel to that what's happening is
uh a new type of food source is
appearing
in this case it was the conifers that
were expanding we're also crowding them
out as as the ferns were dying the
conifers were growing and you have all
these tiny animals that are growing with
the conifers we eventually call them the
dinosaurs they were in the background
they were all these little ants at the
feet of the big um archosaurs by that
time it was the arches of the triassic
and as the big animals finally died the
little guys expanded
and they took over the land they
expanded with the conifers cycads first
and then eventually other conifers and
by the time you get to the cretaceous
you get the same situation now the
plants are dying their eyelids are
shrinking what's taking over
the angiosperms and guess who grew with
angiosperms it was us the mammals
okay
and that's essentially the theory okay
so again all i can say is people say i
should take extinction 101
make sure you understand that well if
you don't agree well all you all you
have to do is propose an alternative
theory
give me a mechanism
uh that is foolproof
and what i mean by foolproof is that
full and full both full and full proof
it's got to be both right
why what are we talking about well we're
saying that uh you got to come up with a
an extinction mechanism
that man cannot do anything about
okay now you say well they throw the
bombs at each other well we can do
something about that we just don't throw
the bombs
and uh well we can we have to have an
asteroid
coming towards the earth but we can nuke
it maybe and turn it into a bunch of
pebbles that certainly won't break the
earth in half
volcanoes can we do something about that
well unless there's a volcano that
cracks open the earth
you know i think we can do a lot about
volcanoes i don't think we have to worry
about volcanoes
supernovas i don't know if that's going
to happen
you know so so they come up with all
these
theories you know some somehow
outrageous ones like egg predation
what the hell is that predation
how do you do egg predation under the
sea you know i mean we have to
find out how the animals in the sea died
as well
and then you have to the the only issue
you know that you have to solve with
extinction is selectivity
how one species survives and the other
one dies both plants and animals
if you can't do that well you got a
problem and especially
going a little more detail it's got to
be chronological selectivity
because what's always died
were the old ones and what survived were
the new plants
you know the the uh
firms they were the old plants when you
compare them against the conifers
and the conifers were the oat plants
when you compare them with against the
angiosperms
and that's how it works
and same with the animals by the way
you know when did the dinosaur start
when did the mammals start well you find
out that they were not they were
staggered they were not they didn't all
start at the same time
and so again
it's chronological cell activity that
you got to explain
i'm not sure an asteroid can explain
cryological selectivity neither can all
this nonsense about methane coming out
of the ground in the permian and all
these other studies that all these great
uh you know scientists scientists
come up with
yeah they've got all these irrational
theories and so yeah uh first you got to
do extension 101 you got to make sure
you understand that well that you can
you know come up with a theory that is
full and foolproof and then yeah then
you you're allowed to talk about humans
whether we're gonna become extinct okay
and i'm saying that the reason humans
are gonna come become extinct has
nothing to do
again with
resources
it has to do with economics
okay
a mass extinction above all is an
economic collapse
all animals do economics
and they have always done so
what is economics it's the management of
resources
what is the resource all man all animals
manage
food
that's their daily tasks they manage
food the lion goes out there he manages
food the cow goes out there manages food
even the ants go out there and manage
food every animal has an economic system
when that economic system collapses that
species collapses and if it's
you know widespread well we call it a
mass extinction
and in the case of man it's not going to
be resources
we we've got resources to lassa for a
long time
because you know right now our economic
system is going to beat that by a mile
our economic system is going to collapse
because it's a an inverted pyramid
scheme
all corporations expect to sell more
next year
and what does more mean means demand
what does demand mean what is demand
population
so yeah population driven but nothing to
do with resources but to do with our
economic system man's artificial
economic system we have a system that's
dependent on demand there's got to be a
pull it's a it's a bootstrap mechanism
you pull on your bootstraps and lift
yourself up that's how our economic
system works
and what we're doing is you know we we
have to have more population
always
demanding more products in fact i could
solve all the problems on earth very
easily if we could have the klingons
right one trillion of them and or the
martians one trillion martians suddenly
put orders
to earth and say we need all your
product we need your food we need your
television sets your
cars your ships your your services
we would be out of a mess
we would have you know we had a trillion
people out there you know
buyers uh demanders uh demanding our
products we would be in good shape
because suddenly you everybody would all
the factories would be put to work
there'd be
lots of uh
jobs uh corporations would be
steaming hot
and the problem we have today is that
we're saturated we you know everybody's
already got all the manufacturing
products that we need you know
everybody's got first a house more or
less a roof over his head
uh everybody's got a you know
refrigerator an oven
washing machine
you replace somewhat every 10 years
whatever
so we don't need those products like we
did when they were first invented
you know when those
items were invented we needed we you
know very few people could have them
because very few people could pay for
them well the prices came down everybody
started having them companies made their
profits they move on to other products
and today we all have these things more
or less
and so the question is yeah we have all
these products so manufacturing now has
died we don't need manufacturing in fact
someone asked a question about that i'll
get to
that in a second uh manufacturing has
manufacturing died on the planet well
it's dying
you know uh big uh companies uh i'm
sorry big countries such as the united
states uh
countries in here in europe
you know 80
85
of their economics uh their gdp right
is uh services
manufacturing is anywhere from 14 to
maybe 20 percent and agriculture's
somewhere around one percent one to two
percent that's it
so we don't do agriculture anymore
because we're so efficient at it that we
don't need people and it's not a big
portion of gdp
manufacturing same thing not a big
portion of gdp or of labor labor is all
in services today and even within labor
even within services i mean
we're moving from hands type labor uh
services
you know
hair cutting and
landscaping you know where you use your
hands
to
we're moving to internet services you
know leisure entertainment we're all in
the entertainment business
and so people are moving into that
everybody wants to hit it big so
everybody say oh i'm going to start in a
youtube site and collect money on ads
and everybody's moving in that direction
and what do you need for that you need
programmers again people moving in that
direction data you know people who put
data in the system and so on so we're
going into this abstract world
and
like i say you know that's unemployment
masked unemployment why is it masked
because you're not really doing anything
what you're doing is passing money
around
i give you your salary you go out there
and give it to someone else that guy
gives it to someone else as long as you
do just services the only time it
becomes productive where you have growth
is where all that money turns into
something tangible
you know you got god and
yourself up there looking at the earth
okay what do you see
how do you determine growth
real growth well you look at buildings
you look at
highways you look at bridges you look at
the the things that you can see
you know
boats and cars and even uh
you know uh
fields of corn and so on
do you see the services do you see the
promises the contracts
do you see your insurance do you see
your banking account
absolutely not there's no such thing
do you see bitcoin no you don't see
bitcoin
bitcoin's just a number in a computer
and like i said the other day as soon as
the russians go out there and knock
those satellites out we have no internet
and that's the end of money because all
money is on the internet
anyways long story the point is what's
going to collapse is our economic system
when it does not if but when it does
no one has any incentive to produce food
what do we die of
food lack of food starvation that's
that's where most of the people probably
die of but then you know after that we
will probably have fireworks we'll have
the nukes being thrown uh
from the russians to the united states
the united states to china and so on
there's gonna be great fireworks so
please stay out at night with your
popcorn bag you know and watch them
so that's gonna be just an added
uh point so it's gonna be a mixture of
starvation together with nuclear weapons
so it's gonna be a lot of fun and i
think that's coming up very quickly uh
i can't even could be months could be
years i don't know i can't tell you i'm
not an astrologer all i can tell you is
i don't see how we can get out of it and
that is a foolproof mechanism because
our system will collapse we cannot grow
forever okay so
there's nothing humans can do about the
economic system
nothing and people say no but we can do
this then no we can't do anything about
services we will move into the service
business and we're going to get farther
and farther away from manufacturing and
agriculture because they're becoming
more efficient as we speak every day
they're becoming more efficient and here
i think i had a
a trend
somewhere i think i'll have it a little
later on but let's move on to another
subject okay and that's uh
kovid okay we have this covet thingy and
paul says there is definitely something
out there i was wondering whether the
other day whether kogit is real
you know i i think it is
you know i got my two shots not because
i believe in it but because i had to
travel to south america just came back a
few days ago and so i got my shots
because they drive you nuts with this uh
pcr test and covet and all this nonsense
you won't believe it
if you haven't traveled well
you better get your shots because
they're going to make life very
miserable on you okay i was skeptic for
a long time because i'm around a lot of
public in my job and somehow i avoided
it until about three months ago i got it
and i instantly realized that i had it
because it had some sym i had some
symptoms i had never had had along with
some that i have had anyway i was better
in a couple of weeks apparently i had
the delta strain
okay
uh one testimony i don't know anyone who
has had covet okay
oh except what i read in the news i mean
but and i've
heard a couple cases similar to this
where the guy was taken to the hospital
but
they told him he had covered he got over
it again in a couple weeks and then he
was let out did he have covet or did he
have the flu i mean i don't know
i i you know i can't vouch for any of
that so
but the only thing that makes me think
that covetous for real again or the main
one is that i don't think cuba and north
korea and iran would cooperate with the
united states
in some kind of global conspiracy to
screw their own populations
that's
the main point that i've got
in favor of the the notion that kobe is
a real bug that's out there okay
and again it's
i'm kind of i like on the fence okay i'm
not gonna put my money in my hand in the
fire for any of this
okay and here's another phone saying
something similar he said i just arrived
back home from visiting a friend in
frankfurt the corona policies are insane
you better believe it and yet kind of
laughable yeah corona uh test centers
are making a killing absolutely in the
united states they're almost 400 bucks
uh for a pcr test are you kidding me 380
bucks
a couple of friends of mine uh the they
lost the test and they had to do it over
again in one case they had to pay for it
all over again
so in order to travel paid almost 800
bucks
unbelievable she wanted to commit
suicide
anyways we'll see what follows my guess
would be another lockdown yeah uh i
think we're in for lockdowns uh now the
winner time
is is this real or is this are they
confusing the
ordinary flu that comes every year
around this time with this kobe thing
i mean i don't know it's just
coincidental that the they found this
new omicron
strain
just when uh
flu season comes
that makes you suspect something and
obviously some people are making a
killing with uh
with corona
so that also kind of um
you know uh makes you wonder uh is there
something real out there or what
okay and here here are the different
variants that you'll see out there okay
we went through the alpha beta we got
the whole uh
alphabet in there and now that they
started with words yeah it used to be
only
letters now we started with words
omicron that's the new one and yeah
they're going to make life miserable for
anyone who doesn't get the shots
and right now with this omicron they
probably are going to request that you
get a booster even if you got uh
the uh
shots like i in my case they're probably
gonna say go get another shot now
and they're free for me they're free but
you know someone's paying for that
through taxes or whatever and companies
are making a big killing on that
aside from putting people to work who
you know take the tests and give you the
shots and all the stuff you know so it
creates labor not in the tourism
business
because the hotels and restaurants there
and the airlines they're doing bad but
all these other people the health
industry i think is booming right now
and i'm not sure you can run the world
on health
not a very profitable industry i mean it
is but it ain't it's not producing
anything
okay uh another topic we had uh talk
about mr
assange and snowden and fellow says the
photo of science and stella could be a
montage the two have been copied uh into
the background
and i'm saying no i'm saying jules
julian there and stella uh they were out
in london and i'll tell you why because
if if
what you say is true
i'm sure assange would have said
something about it like saying hey don't
believe that you know and a lot of big
people would have protested now these
people these two folks were out into the
streets of london
in 2017 they had babies inside the
embassy and like i showed the other day
here was assange talking from the
balcony
to the people out there if the cia the
fbi mi6 mi5 whoever
you know the mossad anyone wanted to
kill him all they had to do just shoot
him right there was an easier shot than
jfk
so don't tell me that this was a montage
and um
so you know my take still remains
uh jules and ed
uh they're both us government operations
okay
now and all i can tell you is i know a
little bit about
spying i spent three years in prison for
it uh so
i know a little bit about how the united
states government runs these things
the uh
um
agencies run these things and i'll give
you a little pointer you know snowden
[Laughter]
when snowden escaped he went to china
first i don't know if you remember that
but he was in china he escaped with his
bag of goodies and he went to china
i can tell you from my own experience
when i went into the cuban embassy when
i went into the iranian embassy when i
went to the chinese embassy
they did treat me very well
in fact they treated me better than very
well when i went to uh you know i was
invited by fidel castro paid for by the
cuban government okay to cuba and i went
to cuba okay they treat you nice because
you get something to give them
and they realize that what you're giving
them is important so they treat you like
you should be treated like someone they
want they they want your information so
you give them the information they treat
you very nice
snowden went there with his bag of
goodies
the chinese government yeah he went to
hong kong the chinese government gave
him 72 hours to leave the country
they did not roll the red carpet they
did not serve him a cup of coffee and
say mr snowden please sit down have a
talk with us they gave them 72 hours to
leave the country
now why would they do that why would the
chinese
lose such an important
an important opportunity here you know
to
to get some information from the us
government here's this guy coming from
information from the nsa
man that should he should have been
treated like like royalty
and he gave him 72 hours to leave the
country and of course snowden left the
country or it was his
bottom
butt you know
and where did he go well he went to
russia
and russia accepted him
is it because the russians are gullible
i mean you got putin he was
in the kgb when when i was working with
him okay
and
and i don't think putin is is an idiot i
mean
all of the the agencies know that
snowden and uh assange are u.s
government operations but they don't
care because those two individuals are
not there to spy against russia or china
they're there to spy on the united
states american people
they're there to that's what the purpose
of them is and so the russians don't
care if snowden stays in moscow i mean
they don't care
he's going to be there to misinform the
us the american people that's his job
and yeah with all these especially you
know you have the anarcho capitalists
and they protest against uh taxes and
they say the u.s government's getting
into my bed and you know they don't have
that power to do that they shouldn't you
know etc and they and they
fight against the us government you know
they they have a different ideology you
could say a different way of thinking
about economics and how the world should
be run and so they oppose a lot of the
decisions that the u.s government makes
and us government says no problem
we're just going to put the leaders
of the anarcho-capitalists
we're going to put someone they respect
someone they'll follow
and that's the job of snowden and
assange they are the leaders of
the opposition
that's the way you conquer them and yeah
it's good uh that's the way it works
some people believe him okay it's up to
you do you believe him okay u.s began as
a constitutional republic says one guy
okay was invaded with the with the
democracy
saya uh
currently operates as a corporation and
is well on the way to oligarchy and he
defines these and i think he's got a
point here again it had concerned me for
about 35 years that people believe we
live in a democracy as they pledge
allegiance to the republic
free republic for which it stands one
nation under god et cetera et cetera
right okay and so yeah he he defines it
he said what is a republic what is
democracy what is a corporation right
command command economy
and what is an oligarchy
and yeah you would think that uh as well
as right i mean does uh the us resemble
more a republic or a democracy or does
it resemble more a like a corporation
and an oligarchy
think about that okay his point is well
taken
okay another fellow along the same lines
he says the following
let me put it over here
he says on democracy we've run the
experiment and it failed just like
everybody in history always said it
would fail
and for the reasons they said it would
fail okay because all you do is create
an oligarchy that can buy its way into
power again all your key some of these
people believe in all the hierarchies
and that's why they had to bring assange
and snowden to convince them just follow
us we fight against the u.s government
just like you do you we're we're going
to be the leaders we're going to be the
generals of this
revolt
and so what we have is a globalist
oligarchy that's brought it bought its
way into power okay and they're burning
down our civilization which is what uh
say oligarchy will do as they they'll
take the commercial and extend it beyond
the moral okay
uh yeah uh a lot of conspiracy theories
all i can say about conspiracy theories
you don't reject them all you got to
choose them carefully okay you don't go
with the flat earthers you don't go with
uh
people who go say that we've never been
to the moon you know they can say
whatever they want
and you know the the intelligence
agencies like to lump all conspiracies
in the same
uh bowl
they like to put them all in there and
say oh all these conspiracies
and so they put the guy who
says that jfk was a conspiracy
together with the guy who says 9 11 was
a conspiracy uh
together with um
you know the flat earthers and the guys
who say that we never went to the moon
so they lump them all together and say
oh they're all these conspiracies
now you got to choose them carefully
because
the intelligence agencies either mine
the field with conspiracies or stimulate
them once they're on the field
so it's in their best interest to create
this
um
potpourri this uh you know this uh many
theories
uh because it confuses people and say
i'm not gonna believe any of those i'll
just go with what the government says
that's what they want you to believe and
so yeah
they mind the field with all these
conspiracies or again
support them you know stimulate them
because it's it's in their best interest
you know who's going to think of
jfk being done by the cia and the mob uh
when uh when you have when those
theories come from what form of
conspiracies who's going to believe them
a conspiracy is a nut nut case
yeah so you don't believe in the guy and
that means you got to accept the
government's version that's the default
okay another fellow says regarding
democracy again here we have it he says
america wasn't even meant to be a
democracy and it still isn't
uh it's a republic people don't vote in
presidents or for president the
electoral college does well you know
it's still a democracy
democracy essentially is uh rule of the
majority you could say that's the
the best way to define it uh and you had
people like plato
and they were against democracy they
said no you it should be the philosopher
kings who rule because you have a small
group essentially a small group of rich
and smart people and you have a
masses of dumb people and you're going
to let the masses of dumb people govern
no he said no you got to have this
oligarchy govern you know the
philosopher kings
and so we have the philosophy gangs we
have trump we have
all these philosopher kings out there
right you gotta bow down to them they're
the rulers
okay and not only here
in the united states or
even in here in germany but you know
putin he's philosophy king in russia you
have she over there in china oh these
are philosopher kings
uh and they're
more like economic kings right
okay there is a hypothesis of how sex
passes from one reproductive to an act
of pleasure
well uh
you know another foul says pleasure is
debate to make reproduction more likely
talking about homosexuality there and
again i'm saying
the argument of the homosexual lobby is
that um
you know sex is for something more than
just reproduction of course they had to
say that because two men cannot have a
kid neither can two women uh you can't
have the trade have the double x with
the xy in order if you want to have a
kid okay
and so uh what i said the other day is
uh this was taken out of a a report you
can see it in the previous lecture says
the transition from prokaryote to
uh
proto-eukaryote to the last again last
eukaryotic common ancestor l-e-c-a last
you very common ancestor uh and what
happened there well during the course of
this evolutionary trajectory the leca
became sexual
in other words what preceded you
eukaryotes
the plants and animals and fungi and all
these other things
what preceded them was already sex
that's why plants have sex and that's
why animals have sex because it was
already in in their genes you could say
it was the previous generation of things
on earth that gave
them this uh property this ability to
have sex and
have uh
offspring but then the question is do
plants have sex because of pleasure
do plants even feel
the pleasure during sex
i mean you have they throw the pollen
and that's a little more less than what
you know we do
you know among humans at least you know
we don't throw pollen at each other you
know we do a little more than that a
little more contact there and so the
question is when they throw pollen do
they have a lot of fun doing that the
plants
do they have
pleasure and if you say no then you know
mother nature did not invent
sex for pleasure
more power to you if you have pleasure
obviously and like this guy says
it's a nice bait but that's only for
animals
i don't think it applies to plants so
it's not a universal this plant this
pleasure thing okay so yeah i don't
think um
at all i do not make that assumption
that uh
sex
has anything to do with pleasure because
otherwise it would be universal i think
it that
it was made mother nature father
universe god the devil whoever you pray
to
they made it for reproduction
and that destroys the homosexual lobby's
argument that
it's okay because sex is for pleasure
it ain't for pleasure okay it's for
reproduction and that obviously destroys
your argument
okay uh regarding the uh fourth
industrial revolution here we have the
fourth uh
the these follows okay uh schwab uh
mosque
these are just three guys there are more
people out there who talk about the
fourth industrial revolution and i
covered that the other day and i said
that you know you have kurzweil he says
the singularity point where the
development of technology becomes so
fast that humanity will no longer will
be able to keep up
this is what these people believe
they're talking about industry when
industry is dying manufacturing is
becoming a smaller percentage of gdp and
of labor on the planet
worldwide okay
and i think that's what i wanted to show
you here um
well anyways kurzweil says i set the
date for the singularity when
2045.
i think he's going to find extinction at
2045 or even before then there's going
to be no fourth
uh
what revolution industrial revolution in
fact in fact i missed two and three i
only knew of one industrial revolution
that was the one in the uh late 18th
century
that's when manufacturing really started
to pick up
and people
got out of the farms they started coming
into the cities in the advanced nations
right and what was left behind was a
more and more and ever
more efficient uh agricultural system
and so yeah the people went to the
cities they started working in the
cities providing the farms the country
with machinery that produced in much
better quantities and quality than when
we had humans working you know with a
scythe and so on and so this was the
industrial revolution the only one i
know after that uh what these people are
talking about is some minor changes we
went from machinery to electronics
great they call that the revolution now
revolution is when you involve the
masses that's a revolution revolution is
what happened in uh france
uh in the late 18th century what
happened in uh russia the beginning of
the 20th 20th century
that's that's a revolution masses of
people going out there doing something
that's a revolution but revolution
saying that you changed
machinery with electronics and now you
start governing with robots instead of
with humans that's not a revolution okay
that just shows that we're dying in
manufacturing and what's rising is
services okay
and so here um
fellow says
pre-decides he might come and i said
manufacturing is over he says maybe in
europe or
usa canada what about china india and
russia
and i'm saying this is a global
phenomena manufacturing is dying
globally okay that's the first thing i'm
going to say the second one is poor
countries are trying to emulate they're
trying to imitate the rich countries
everybody wants to have what services
everybody's moving into services and
abandoning manufacturing because
manufacturing because of the technology
that we've invented has become more
efficient
and even the like i said the hands-on
services are dying you go to the airport
no checking agents
you go to the bank
no bank tellers
you got these machines you know
put the card in
you go to the
food store
or any store for that matter and you
have self-checkout no cashiers
everything
you know these entry levels
are dying
hands-on they're dying and we have this
automated system uh
internet right it's all done through
the internet
okay you put your card in you get you
paid you take your stuff out you're done
so everything's becoming automated and
that's killing manufacturing
okay so so yeah it's happening across
the board i mean i went to iceland the
other day what was in may it scared me
one of the most advanced countries in
the world also one of the i think it is
the most expensive country in the world
and what do you find in reykjavik you
got a store
i didn't even know because you know i'm
old-fashioned i'm from 20th century guys
and i go in there it's all machines you
got to pass your card through it and do
your own thing and it's like uh could
you please come over here and help me
and hopefully
i didn't talk to a robot i think it was
a real human being but here was one
you can call them cashiers i don't know
what you call them there's one person
there
and they handle several machines and
they're there only to help you in case
you don't know how to handle the machine
or they're there to educate you
essentially same thing at the airport
you go there you don't know how to run
the machine and they come over there's
one person attending like 500
you know uh checking machines and they
come and help you because you might have
a problem
so they got rid of all these check-in
agents all these cashiers all these bank
tellers
lots of jobs died there and where did
all these people go well they go to the
internet and they say maybe i can hit it
big in youtube just putting something
that creates ads and i get ad money
every month
that's where we're headed okay and now
that's unemployment that's what it's
called masked unemployment we don't live
out of singing and acting and
bsing like me lecturing you know
we can't all live with that we're not
producing anything
we're just passing the bug
okay so yeah services especially
internet services it's known as
unemployment i'm retired
just in case okay and then technology
efficiency automation that's also
driving manufacturing out and here you
see here's you see a little bit of what
i'm talking about okay here's the
global decline in manufacturing okay
it's dying it's been dying since at
least since the 1980s if you go farther
back in time you'll find even a bigger
drop but you can see what's happening to
the global
manufacturing it's dying everywhere
so yeah this notion that people have
that or that this person raised that
manufacturing is is still rising
especially in third world countries that
it's only moved
that it's subcontracted so to speak that
you know the big corporations are simply
taking all this stuff and putting it in
india and
china and other countries no over there
as well what was it i think it was 2016
you can say maybe 2017 don't quote me on
that one but around there 2016 2016-17
in china services for the first time
surpassed manufacturing as a percentage
of gdp it was 50 plus one
okay check it out you'll find out
china today is a service oriented
economy not a manufacturing economy of
course it's got a lot of manufacturing
and it is automating heavily
pushing people into services but that's
what's going on in china so if china is
becoming served a service economy what
does what is going to happen to
manufacturing to industry
and you can say that about every country
in the world
in fact i was reading that puerto rico
is the number one country's got still
more manufacturing as a percentage of
gdp than anyone else almost 50 percent i
don't know why maybe they process
bananas
banana country
not even a country just the
commonwealth okay and so here's my graph
for what's happening to
humans
okay essentially why manufacturing is
dying also it's all part of the same
theory okay we spent
maybe 200 300 000 years in hunters as
hunters that was what we did for most of
our existence from there we moved to
farming maybe the last 10 000 years
neolithic and so on from there about 300
years ago
200 300 years ago we moved into
manufacturing we started this
industrialization process
and uh last 30 40 50 years maybe uh we
went into services and now for the last
10 years we're heavily moving into
internet services
okay
and so we went from we're going from
labor intensive services uh like i just
explained
to internet services
and the question is what's next
okay
and yeah it's um
i don't think there's much of a future
in the way we're headed
okay because what's next what do you
what are we gonna invent next you can
see what's happened with the not only
with the timing the fact that we spent
most of our existence as hunters then we
went to agriculture small piece of that
uh whole
range of time uh only 10 000 years
which is a drop
of water almost when you consider that
we've been around for 300 000 years and
not to mention industry you know
manufacturing 300 years maybe
we'll give it 400 years to help them out
and service is what 40 50 60 years
the date i've got at least for the
transition for the united states in a
country like sweden
they
made the crossover from manufacturing
the services in 1979
around you know
the time that they had the
gold standard
pulled out okay the bretton woods
accords and so on around that time
that's when they switched over from
being manufacturing countries they call
them industrialized countries they don't
use that term anymore because now
they're not industrialized
now they're servicized i guess you could
no now they're calling advanced nations
or whatever you know they have different
terms for that now
and what are all the other countries
trying to do they're trying to imitate
the industrial the
ex-industrialized countries they all
want to have services
and so here's the question i mean
services what's next and if you can't
think of anything else because there
ain't anything else
service is the end of the line are we
going to remain in services now for the
next million years
okay so that's the question that i put
the other day
some people have well a couple of people
have answered it i'm going to
get back to that subject next time
around
okay let's move on to physics okay the
physics what did we cover this month
well let's go real quickly on the recap
here it is
okay we have this we have these
gentlemen uh throughout history
and uh all the way from galileo to mr
stephen gawking
and all these people came up with all
these ideas that we have known as
mathematical physics and what what is
mathematical physics well it's
irrational explanations that's all we
see they say well we've got all these
equations look at the technology we have
yeah
that's got nothing to do with science
technology and science are two different
uh disciplines
branches whatever
uh
technology is not even a part of science
science rational explanations
that's what science is people want to
know how this universe works and if
we're going to become extinct very soon
hopefully we all die at least
understanding how this universe works
then we can all go to bed
okay but right now you know uh
most people in the world believe these
folks and what they have is irrational
explanations of how this universe works
okay and so we covered what uh the
differences between math and biz okay in
mathematics they talk about distance but
it's not distance known as distance
traveled
distance traveled is not the same thing
as distance distance belongs exclusively
to physics distance traveled belongs
exclusively to math so when you look at
the equations of force okay that
supposedly newton came up with obviously
like i said the other day there were
ideas even before newton uh on these
issues but for the sake of argument
we're going to assign them to newton so
that we can at least use his name we
have his second law force equals mass
times acceleration and
it's not equal to
the gravitational equation which is
force equals the gravitational constant
g mass 1 mass 2 divided by distance
squared
and they're not equal the mathematicians
constantly put them as equal because
they play around with the numbers
but they don't play around with the
qualitative notions that underlie
these two
uh
equations what's the difference well
again
distance traveled is what you have in
the force equals mass times acceleration
that acceleration
is it has to do with distance traveled
this can travel by one
object that object starts at a given
point
moves forward they look at how much it
traveled how many meters they they put
one meter after another they count meter
or unroll the measuring tape and they
say three meters
okay and that's a value they're going to
put in there that distance traveled is
the distance traveled by the tip of your
measuring tape
okay so we're looking at the roll
unrolling of your measuring tape and
that
measuring tape the tip of your measuring
tape travels from point a to point b
three meters
distance traveled by one object the tip
of your measuring tape that's different
than what you see in the gravitational
equation that distance squared there is
separation
between mass 1 and mass 2.
that distance is not the same distance
traveled as the second law force equals
mass times acceleration
one is dynamic the other one is a static
concept
then uh newton's equation second law
there it's it's a equation of push
because it's
the object is moving from point a to
point b
on the other hand the other one you know
gravity we call it pull the pull of
gravity but actually it's tension
what you have is tension because all
you're looking at is the separation
between two objects nothing is moving
because you just want to calculate one
value and so conceptually what you have
separation between two objects and at
that point they're just static nothing's
moving we call that tension
and tension is not a force tension does
not meet the definition of the word
force what is force
well it's got to have motion
and tension is the opposite it's a
static concept tension means
there
it's like
uh two objects separated by a stick
made of a single piece that's what
tension is and say well but we're
pulling okay so you know here here we
have a rubber band let me get a smaller
one here
here we have a rubber band
and i'm going to put to mat well it's
not max but i don't want to rip it but
let's say i'm pulling you completely to
max it can't move anymore in in any
direction
well at that point in time there is
uh
no force it's not moving this way it's
not moving that way and force requires
that someone win the tug of war right
now no one's winning the tug of war this
thing is stretched to max
that's called tension tension is
uh like if the two objects were
separated by a stick made of a single
piece
that's tension and that's newton's
gravitational equation
then uh you know we play around with
those and we put force divided by
acceleration that gives us mass in the
second law right
but mass is equal to weight
and the mathematicians say well it's not
true mass is not weight weight is not
mass they're two different things
well are they
that looks to me like they're the same
because
the mathematicians use the word mass to
refer to weight
what are they talking about they're
saying well uh you know if an object
increases in speed against
or the pressure right against the scale
they call that mass
wasn't it einstein who said that you
know the object travels at near
the speed of light
and
as it travels faster and faster faster
it its mass increases
so what are you saying that it gained
more atoms is is that what einstein was
saying
it becomes fatter
because suddenly you know it's gaining
more atoms in it
you know here you are you're traveling
at almost the speed of light and you're
traveling faster and faster faster
you're gaining more mass what do you
mean more atoms
or is it that you're pressing against
the scale
with a
greater pressure
well if you're doing that then you're
doing weight you're not doing mass but
they call it mass that's the issue there
and uh moving on uh work what is work
well work um
if you just do it on a horizontal plane
we said uh that's just force times
acceleration but then if you're going to
go on an inclined plane now you're going
to have to factor gravity in there
and instead of looking at the what
happens in physics which is factoring
gravity whatever gravity is right
physically
instead of factoring that they said oh
we solve this very easily we we just
take the uh cosine of the angle you know
and uh depending on the
angle that you have for that inclined
plane and we calculate it
well that's okay in mathematics what
does that tell me about physics
in physics we need to know the cause why
why suddenly it's become
harder to push the ball upstream than it
was rolling it on on a horizontal plane
and for that you have to factor gravity
and they don't do that they just do a
calculation based on cosine of a and
we're done
that's how they so they calculate it
yeah and the calculation is correct no
i'm we're not arguing against that we're
saying we don't understand the physics
why did it suddenly become harder to
push that ball up the incline plane and
they say well because we have cosine of
a well that's not a reason that's a
description
that's an equation you haven't told me
the cause the physical cause
energy oh the big word energy biggest
word in mathematical physics whenever
you you're very ignorant you don't know
something just say energy and you're
done with it's like in uh old uh
religions of traditional religions they
would say the spirit did it oh okay we
and we all understood that because
why did the curtain move well the spirit
moved it
and you know the spirit flies of spirit
mostly air you know all that stuff is
done by the spirit
and energy is a spirit is a spirit of
mathematics mathematics i'm sorry
uh
whenever you don't know something just
use the word energy and you're done
because everybody says oh now i
understand
did you
because they define it as the capacity
which is a concept
capacity is a kind there is no physical
standalone object called capacity please
draw it put it in front of me
get some clay and mold it and i want to
know what capacity looks like
and now you can't do that but they treat
it as an object they say we transferred
energy
what do you mean you transferred
what is this
and they say well it's a figure of
speech you know you don't have to take
it literally
in physics we take the explanation the
mechanism
literally
now if you want to
use uh you know parables or whatever for
your closing arguments that's just fine
you want to use poetry that's great
no problem but the
meat of your theory your explanation
your mechanism had better be literal
okay
that's the way it works in science and
no these people say these people use
that uh parable that figure of speech
whatever you want to call it
that's what they use to give your ex
their explanations
and when you put them against the wall
and you begin pounding them at the
corner they say well that's not physics
anyways that's philosophy
and so why did you even attempt to do
philosophy if it's not part of your
discipline if your discipline known as
mathematical physics has to do with
descriptions mathematical descriptions
predictions observations uh
measurement whatever you want to call
all that nonsense
if it's got to do with all that why did
you even attempt to give a physical
interpretation to your equation if the
physical interpretation is irrational
and when i put you against the wall and
begin pounding you you say well that's
philosophy anyways
why did you try to do philosophy
you should have stuck to doing your math
and we there would be a fight
we have a fight because you're claiming
that you understand something about the
physical world
and you're giving me an equation give me
an irrational explanation and when i
call your bluff
you say well that's philosophy anyways
we don't do that we have no way of
proving and that's not scientific
anyways
that's what you get today
okay and we covered then the pendulum
the last part that covered the other day
and none of these folks from galileo all
the way to good old stephen gawking none
of these people ever discovered the
mechanism they do have the equations
they can tell you that to the
i don't know to the last decimal point
great
uh they still don't know why
a pendulum moves like that okay
and yeah we do and here it is okay
here's the explanation
every atom of the pendulum is tied bound
physically bound to every atom on earth
we only show those
ropes that are bound to the center of
the earth because that's where
all the ropes are converging upon so the
the the pool you could say is towards
the center of the earth okay and that's
what moves the pendulum and all these
people all these great mathematicians
the reason they never
figured this out is they said well i
don't see any rope i can't touch any
rope what are you talking about bill
i mean you know
where are these ropes
you know i i don't see them and so so we
have to begin at square one you know and
we do it with a little pencil don't ever
do this experiment at home okay unless
you are in the presence of a relativist
okay because it's a very dangerous
experiment and we let go of the pencil
and it falls to
the center of the earth really to the
floor to my table in this case okay
let's do it again you got to do
repeatable otherwise it's not scientific
they say okay so we repeat it
that's part of the scientific method of
the mathematicians and there it is okay
it fell two times to the ground now why
didn't it fall to the ceiling that's
what we want to know that's what we want
to understand
and yeah you can see
or better the opposite you can't see you
don't see anything here you don't see
anything here
and uh so if there's nothing here and
there's nothing here other than air and
we know that air is not the one that's
causing this because we can do this in
outer space when there is no air or on
the moon as they did it you know uh we
can drop
for those who believe that we went to
the moon
gotta specify that okay uh there's
nothing here nothing there so what
pushed it what pushed the pencil
downwards what pulled it
that's what you got to explain
and you say well i can't see or touch
anything other than there right
and yeah what that tells us is that
there is something that came in contact
with the skin of the pen
that we can't see
or touch
so we're not going to be figuring this
out by running experiments because we
cannot see
or touch
the mediators of gravity
okay and that's what they missed all
these years so
we come in there we said well if you're
gonna make this if you're going to make
this phenomenon
rational
you had better put some physical
entities here somewhere
and a lot of people put particles they
said particles are pushing down on the
pen
well that's irrational for many
reasons what we say here is that every
atom of the pen is tied is bound to
every atom on earth
okay so every atom of the pen is bound
to every atom on earth and so when we
let go of it
it drifts in that direction because as
it falls because that's the direction in
which all the ropes are essentially
directed
as it falls
the
roast fan out and the angles become
greater and greater and more independent
ropes
uh act
with the uh on the pen
and that's why the pin falls downwards
and there are fewer ropes connected
towards the ceiling and to the stars and
whatever so yeah uh because of distance
not distance traveled but because of
distance the separation between the
center of the earth and the pen
the pen tends to go in that direction
accelerates downwards oh and again it's
an acceleration it increases why because
the ropes are fanning out as this thing
falls closer and closer to the center of
the earth it also shows why
the earth is a sphere and not
a little pancake as the flat earthers
say okay
the pancake earth that's what they
believe in
okay and here's uh
another uh file says we measure mass by
putting it on a scale
no no uh we don't measure
mass because mass is the quantity of
matter meaning you're going to count
apples that's what mass is counting
apples so you have to say 10 apples and
so you don't measure mass you count
units of mass and you should state your
answers in terms of those units you can
say
this has a mass of one gazillion atoms
for example
or units of mass whatever
then we would understand that would be
the way to state quantity of matter
so we do not measure and give you a
value in kilograms because that's known
as weight
okay
so it's called weight mass you count
units okay so this guy insists he says
the word mass has two meanings in
special relative well he doesn't say
that by the way uh this i get from um
the wikipedia okay just to show where
the sky stands so the word mass has two
meanings in special relativity rest mass
is an invariant quantity what are you
talking about quantity of matter in
other words mass and then relativistic
mass is independent or is dependent on
velocity what are you talking about
they're talking about weight because now
you're talking about how much pressure
you're causing
you know on the on the scale
so
uh relativistic mass is not mass they
can call it relativistic weight if they
want but that's not mass
and this is where we get uh into
circular arguments because these people
say it's mass and they're not mass
they're talking about weight
and so uh yeah the question is did the
object accumulate more atoms meaning
quantity of matter or did the object
increase pressure against the scale
which is weight
so again yeah it is that they confuse
the word mass with weight they don't
like to talk about weight because they
know that weight
varies uh according to
where you measure for example if you
measure on the moon uh the ball is going
to weigh a little less right
about a six less and so
or a sixth of what it weighs here on
earth but this what does this tell us
they're telling us that the mass remains
the same what do you mean the mass
remains the same how do you determine
mass you weigh it
there he said you put it on a scale
that's how you determine uh
mass and yeah if you're gonna determine
mass by putting it on a scale
uh then you're doing weight
and so again uh
they're chasing their tails around
they're saying mass is weight wages mass
they're calling weight mass
and they just drive you nuts because
they just go around in circles so this
fall continues he says well here
he says to calculate number of atoms in
a sample divide its mass measurement in
grams by the amu atomic mass unit right
from the periodic table then multiply
the result by avogadro's number 6 times
10 to the 23rd
okay uh so that's the calculated atoms
then you should state
mass in terms of quantity of atoms okay
that's what you should do you can't
state in terms of kilograms because
that's not what you just said what you
said is
we weigh it and then we turn it using
avogadro's number we turn it into
quantity of atoms great i have no
problem with it then state your mass in
terms of atoms don't state it in terms
of kilograms
kilograms weight
they say no no that's measured in
newtons nobody uses newton nobody says i
weigh 500 newtons
nobody says that okay everybody says i
weigh 500 pounds
or whatever that's what they'll say
nobody uses newtons
they use
pounds and kilograms for weight
and they say well but that's mass no
because you defined it as quantity of
atoms as quantity of matter and there if
you have a way of calculating it great
that's even more power to you give it
give your answer in terms of quantity of
atoms or units of mass or whatever you
want to call it
that's the way it
works hey
so uh yeah big confusion with mass and
wait a lot of people
just uh recite what they learned by
wrote in high school or college and here
we
correct them
we set them straight okay
and
when they don't understand
uh we use the bill gateway
we uh
teach them we teach them the the bill
gateway okay baseball bat
therapy
another foul says if the mass of enegic
is meant to be equivalent to the number
of atoms yeah
then how can an elementary particle have
mass since there is nothing there to
count
what do you mean there's nothing there
to count you have their one elementary
particle fundamental particle and we
have one unit of mass
that is your unit of mass
let me tell you what the problem is
the problem here is that
the mathematician especially the quantum
mathematicians the mechanics right what
they say is oh we we have an elementary
particle we have a fundamental particle
for example the electron or maybe the
gluon or one of those right and they'll
say that's an elementary particle photon
okay what do they mean by that it's a
particle that's indivisible
uh made of a single piece
is that the notion they're trying to
convey to you
made of a single piece indivisible that
it has no internal structure whichever
way they want to phrase it no problem
but what happens the reporter at the end
of the room he says
what is it made of
and that's when they run into trouble
because what these people answer they
should have said well elementary
particle fundamental particle by
definition is one that's not made of
anything
that's not what they answer
what they answer they say well give us
more money
and we'll be
build a bigger collider
one that has
the radius or the orbit of pluto
will smash it and will turn and will
tell you what it's made out of
that's what they answer
and so yeah they go out there and they
give more money and they say okay now we
have the cern the lhc
okay great and they go in there and they
smash
this alleged particle this indivisible
and they smash and they say okay the
alpha particle is made out of betas
and so they give the presentation to the
world we found the beta
and the reporter at the end of the
room says uh what is it made out of
say okay give us more money we'll build
a bigger colliders because the galaxy
well smashing will tell you what beta is
made out of
and and so quantum mechanics is one of
those things that
is eternal it gives them job security
forever because they just say well it's
an elementary particle and when they say
what is it made out of they say give us
more money and we'll tell you
and so that here they are always
smashing what they think are particles
they think they're smashing them you
know crashing one against the other and
getting all this debris and saying and
giving them names they get nobel prizes
for this you know they say okay i found
a little bit of the
alpha particle now it's i got the beta
particle okay and then the delta and the
gamma and whatever and so we have the
gamma particle what is the gamma made up
well give us more money and we'll smash
it and we'll tell you what it is and the
money keeps rolling and they keep giving
you this run around
and
you see you see we have a problem
because you would think that quantum
mechanics
ultimately conceptually
not a question of
running experiments conceptually
should have a fundamental particle that
makes up everything else
and this should be
um
a hypothetical particle
you don't have to see it you don't have
to go to a lab and say let me detect it
no none of that
from a conceptual point of view there
should be an ultimate particle because
you can't divide the ultimate particle
and end up with nothing
okay
uh because that ultimate partnership
particles should make up everything else
that should be their starting point from
a conceptual point of view
that underlies
quantum
mechanics you understand what i'm saying
i'm saying there has to be an oh the
buck has to stop there somewhere
and they don't do it that way they go
the other way around they say well we
smash particles we give them fancy names
get nobel prizes and if you want to know
what that particle is made out of give
us more money and we'll smash that one
too
but that doesn't give us the conceptual
foundation for quantum mechanics
conceptual foundation should be there
should be an ultimate particle we'll
call it the z particle fine you can't
break up z it's the ultimate particle
and that makes up everything else now
present your theory to me present your
your entire theory based on that
fundamental elementary particle
and they don't do it that way because
they would be dead in the water if they
did it that way that would be the end of
quantum mechanics because now we reach
the end of the line so well for the next
million years we're going to be smashing
particles trying to get the next level
particle is that what it is
yeah
okay let's go with some of the questions
some of people
raised uh some of the issues they raised
uh one fellow said veritasium the big
misconception about electricity i talked
about that last time and he says has
been getting a lot of reactions from
those who think they know different can
you make a video and show what it is uh
wrong also what is wrong also i did uh
you probably missed it so here it is uh
you look up
uh this follow uh
derek muller and uh if you look up my
video known as transferring energy
you'll find mr derrick in there and i've
i think i discussed that at least the
main points uh quite well so just look
up that video and you'll come up to
speed
okay next issue file says
what do you care so much this current
definition of science
to describe and or to develop technology
uh-huh
even if it's corrupted from history then
why not inventing a new word
so he's saying i shouldn't use the word
science because that's what people
understand by science that's what they
were educated to
say at high school and college level and
they say science is this you know uh
description or whatever
well we can go with almost any word
what is an object
well you know we have a different
definition here of the word object
that's a key word and so they're going
to say well why don't you invent a
different word if you have a different
definition or a very restricted
definition use a different word
and how about the word exists you know
nobody has defined the word exist even
though physics is the science of
existence physics deals with what exists
and
mathematical physics has never defined
the word exists because they don't do
qualitative stuff they just do math and
so they say well why don't you get
another word if
we this is our definition you get
yourself your own word and so here they
want me to get a different word for
every word that i use which is critical
to physics so the word science the word
physics itself uh object uh thing uh
exist location
um motion
time we don't use time have no use for
time that's a mathematical concept but
you have all these words out there
concept you know what is a concept all
these words out there
they want me to get a different def uh a
different word for them because they say
that they're copyrighted or something
the word is copyright we use it in
mathematical physics you get your own
no no it's the other way around it's if
something is wrong if something is
broken you fix it
and mathematical physics is broken
because they've never defined any of
these words they don't have a word a
definition for their own words such as
energy mass they have what seven
definitions of mass they have four
definitions of weight
they have i don't know how many
notions of uh energy like 12 or 15
so they don't have definition they don't
know what time is
they don't know what motion is they
can't define motion so they don't have
definition for any of these words
and so
it's broken and we came to fix it
and if they don't like our definitions
because it destroys their religion
well all they can do is get inside the
ring with shield and sword and fight for
their definitions they have to defend
their definition and not say go get
yourself your own definitions
no it doesn't work that way okay so if
science is misdefined and they've been
doing
what observation prediction
experiments math measurement equations
none of that is science that's not
science evidence proof none of that is
science
science explanations
rational explanations and we have to
define the word rational because people
say well rationalize your opinion
we have a definition for rational as
well so sorry
if you don't like our definition of
rational get inside the ring fight for
your definition of rational otherwise
you're irrational because you you're not
willing to fight for your definition
so yeah we're not going to change the
language
in the sense that we're going to
introduce new words no
we're going to be using the same words
we're just going to define them properly
okay another issue
a touchy issue
paul says
if separate objects can touch
then how do they push pull in physics
two objects may never touch
otherwise they fuse
then what keeps them apart
the force
the force may the force go with you
irrationally justifying your incomplete
definition of object
and all i can say is this fellow uh he's
confusing the context
uh what are we talking about here you
know he hasn't specified but he gets
bits and pieces here and he kind of
jumbles them all into one
argument and are we talking about the
macro world or the invisible world of
mother natures are we talking about
quantum mechanics or the rope hypothesis
are we talking about you know particles
or the rope
or
are we talking real world scenarios here
or definitions
what are you talking about what are you
referring to
this guy mixed up a lot of stuff in
there and so let's go through this in in
a little detail so that people
understand a little more of what this
guy is talking about okay
so let's go in there
and here we have the mathematical
physics world versus the rope hypothesis
okay what is the difference well
mathematical physics for the last 10 000
years
has proposed that particles discrete
particles even the wave
uh transverse wave that's particle
what's shaking up and down a bunch of
particles so
and even the dissidents electric
universe uh the john chappelle society
all these people talk about particles
and what's different from ours well
we're saying that
all atoms are physically interconnected
one atom is connected to another one is
it because it's attached by something no
there's a single thread in the whole of
space and here it is
okay this is a single
uh thread
and that makes up all the atoms which
turn into ropes which turn into atoms
which turn into ropes so everything is
connected in that sense there's a single
thread underlying all the matter and all
the so-called energy in the universe
light because light is mediated by a
rope a rope like uh entity and so atoms
are bound by the electromagnetic rope
the rope is not attached okay and
there's a continuous thread that
constitutes all atoms and ropes okay
it's a single closed loop thread okay
that's all there is in the universe
floating
you can say in space even though that's
incorrect in physics we don't say that
it's in space because space is not a
container
okay uh not an object not a thing space
is nothing that which has no shape and
then
the surface of the atom pushes on
another atom
so when two atoms come together when
they meet uh the push is simply the
pressure one atom exerts on another
that's how simple it is and the pull of
gravity is is the opposite when um
when uh uh
atoms are
forming one object are attracted to
another object
uh the ropes fan out that's what it is
so it's very straightforward and here
you have two atoms okay interconnected
by a rope this is a centenart model but
that rope doesn't stop at the atom okay
it's a single thread that you see on the
right
okay so uh that's what you got to think
of it as it's just two atoms that are
physically
interconnected by
by this thread this twine thread this
twine pair of threads
there's a single
thread in the entire universe that in
other words here it is let me show it to
you
here
this is what we're talking about this is
all there is in the universe this
underlies matter
it's just a single thread that turns
into atoms which turn into thread uh
ropes which turn into atoms which turn
into ropes that's all there is okay it's
a simple universe okay this is what
these people missed
uh why is it
intangible it's intangible and uh
unseeable
because
hopefully if you're going to explain
um
why this pencil falls to the floor
you have to explain invisibility and
intangibility because that's what we see
or what we feel what we experience
with gravity
if it were touchable if i could touch
this
we'd be in a lot of trouble i wouldn't
be explaining gravity because the
mediator of gravity is intangible and
invisible
but uh more fundamental on that
an object is that not that which you can
see or touch an object is that which has
shape that does not mean that you can
see or touch it
so there are several arguments
underlying
uh intangibility and uh invisibility
okay here we have the pull of gravity
okay
so that you can see how it's done under
the rope model
okay so we have these
uh two objects they're separated by a
lot of distance
okay and they come together as they come
together the ropes fan out and that's
the acceleration of gravity that's what
it's called okay there you see it step
by step
okay
that's our model okay what we're saying
is that as an object approaches another
the ropes fan out and you can put any
object you want in there and as you can
see all those atoms you can imagine all
those atoms being connected to all other
atoms in the universe all atoms are
physically connected because there's a
single thread going through all of them
that's
that's the
uh theory or the assumption and from
there we explain gravity light magnetism
and so on all the invisible stuff okay
uh regarding touch he mentions that two
objects may never touch
okay so here we have uh
the situation
okay here's
uh two balls out there that's all god
made okay so god was not very smart in
those days he became smarter later on in
life
but when he started out he started out
very simple he just created two objects
he put him there
and he didn't know what to do with them
and at some point you know he went in
there and he said okay
he started uh
putting them into motion here we're
gonna put him into motion okay god's
gonna move his magic wand abracadabrance
they started moving
okay
so uh
so now we have this situation where the
two objects are together and the
question is you know are they touching
and people will say well yeah they're
touching
and why are they touching and you say
well they're touching because you know
you have one surface against another we
call that touch in our world don't we
and the answer is no
these two objects are not touching
because they're surrounded by that black
stuff known as space
for otherwise they wouldn't have a
surface uh if if there was some if there
wasn't any space there
each of those objects would be
infinite in extent
would be infinite objects and that would
be the a contradiction with the
definition of the word object which is
that which has shape and shape hopefully
is finite not infinite
so there is no such thing as an infinite
object because that's a
an oxymoron it's a self-contradiction
and so right now you have two balls
there and they're not touching and you
can press them any
harder and harder and harder as much as
you want and they'll never be touching
because there's always space surrounding
each one of the two objects
in order
for um
for there to be
touching then you have to have
them you know
they would have to form a single object
they would have to form uh they would
have to turn into a single object and
with the rope model yeah we can we do
have that in the real world here you see
two hydrogen atoms and they're made out
of all these threads that come from
every atom in the universe
and if when these two uh
atoms come together
well yeah they merge if if they're both
going in the same direction in other
ways spinning in the same direction they
merge and they form the h2 molecule the
h2 gas molecule
and so yes we do have
two objects becoming one in the real
world
in these scenarios because two objects
become one okay and yeah you can go
forever and talk about um
you know the ropes and the threads and
talk about that no the what you gotta
have here is um the
uh you have to consider the system and
what is the system that we're talking
about we're talking about
uh just the atoms
so don't go any deeper than that and say
well what about the threads what about
the ropes no no you got to tell me what
what system you're talking about you're
talking about two ropes getting uh
merging are you talking about two
threads merging or are you talking about
two atoms merch here we're talking about
two atoms okay
so that's the situation now the one i
just explained about the two uh atoms
emerging uh two balls merging out there
god's two two little balls that he
created
that's a hypothetical situation that's
to
give you a notion of why
or how we came up with the word touch
touch means
two objects that convert that converge
and become one
that's what touch means if you press
with your finger against your other
finger your two fingers have not become
one there's still space separating your
two fingers
and you say well i press harder and
harder when you still you have two
objects
the only way you're going to have one
object if these two fingers merge
they blend become one then then you have
uh
then you can say you have uh touch
as long as space separates them
and space does separate them right here
because otherwise i wouldn't have two i
would have one then space has to be
between them and i can press as much as
i want i will not convert them into one
same when you press against the table or
whatever
so keep all that in mind we're talking
about the definition these people go out
there and say well what about this i'm
gonna
keep it in the context the context we're
trying to define the word touch
which mathematical physics has never
defined even though they talk about
collisions and you say well collision
what do you mean collision did they
touch each other
and that's when they say well you have
the field and
and that's when you say i need a beer
okay
another guy says is it possible to draw
an object that doesn't have shape
[Laughter]
yeah guys i get these kinds of questions
what do you want me to do
this is these are the questions that
keep people up at night and they say
can you draw an object that doesn't have
shade my god
well all i can do is define the word
object forum so that we can bring them
down to earth okay poor fellow uh here
it is science rational explanations it's
divided into two portions physics and
philosophy
and from physics we do physics here okay
we have the golden principle of physics
which is the fundamental cornerstone you
could say
and what is it physics requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object okay you need objects to do
physics if god had not made
objects out there
then there would be no physics okay we
have to have objects if we want to do
motion if we want to do talk about
existence
if we want to
have things collide or move around or
behave in some way so you need objects
that's the first principle of physics
what is an object is it that which you
can see or touch absolutely not
it's that which has shape
and
there's my comment uh the scientific
definition of the word object destroys
all religions that's why these people
ask all these questions because they see
that they're
that this definition stands in their way
in the way of their theory of what they
believe in
of uh
how they want to explain things how they
want to explain the workings of the
universe and the word object destroys
their arguments
this is where they have a problem
okay and along the same lines last issue
here we have this your explanation for
the definition of object which the
example between earth klingon
has
a number of logical problems okay and he
goes through this
and
he never
really shows what the problem is i'll
just skip a couple steps you can read it
later but it says bill shows a pen and
says that it is an object and because it
has shape but because he touches it and
sees it that's not what i say but this
is what he's putting words in my mouth
but the klingon klingonian
is not a pen
he's not a pen well hopefully
it is not even an object because he can
neither touch nor see it
my god poor fellow and
he says this is essentially his argument
this this is all he really says that he
could care less about what the klingon
or the earthman has at home
if these two are perfectly isolated in
other words we shouldn't even ask the
question of whether because he's talking
about this situation here let me show it
to you yeah he's talking about this
which i covered in the past okay and
that's that you have
because we're destroying the definition
c touch
of mathematics okay an object is not
that which you can see or touch because
you cannot see or touch the table that
the klingon has on the other side of the
universe and so the question is is that
table that is a table to the cling on is
that a table for us because under our
definition of mathematical physics uh
that's not a that's not an object
because we can't see or touch it
and so that's the issue what this guy
understood i have no idea but it just
gives you an uh a notion of what some
people are thinking of over the you know
in this world of theirs this tiny world
of theirs so we were only talking about
the word object this guy brings in the
word exist
because in mathematical physics the word
object and the word exists are synonyms
okay that's that's the way they've
treated it hume can't uh ain't rand all
these people
talked in the same way wittenstein they
all thought of an object and the word
exists being synonyms what are they
see touch if you can see or touch it or
touch it
and or touch it
it's a thing it's an object and does it
exist well if you can see and or touch
it then it exists also so the word
object and exist are synonyms in
mathematical physics in philosophy and
all these disciplines out there they
they consider them synonyms and we say
no there's a big difference object that
which i shape
exists
an object that has location
if god wants to exist
he not only has to be an object he can't
be a concept such as love or
intelligence he's got to be an object
like a human being maybe a burning bush
that's fine
and on top of that
that thing that he is has to have
location there has to be distance
between that thing and my chest then you
can say god exists otherwise god is
irrelevant
okay
okay let's get on with some of the
questions i don't have ons today he's on
a secret mission
so uh when he goes back uh we'll
we'll do this together for now let me
just go with see what kind of questions
people ask what kind of comments see if
there's anything worthwhile out there
okay so give me a second here
one thousand what is the oxymoronic
invisible intangible physical mechanism
thread made of
it's an elementary entity
and so look up elementary entity is one
that is not made of anything okay very
simple uh
[Music]
milton's friedman's son is even worse
economist than his papa okay
casey katie doesn't understand economics
okay
good uh how do you determine growth okay
i agree with him on the collapse of the
central banks what would you okay
currency collapse will mean starvation
yes
absolutely
uh roughly speaking growth products cost
me okay but
it says i'm missing a critical component
energy no such monster is energy
okay as we just discussed
and again uh talking about energy uh in
regards to
um
the
the uh what is it the um
energy crisis or the uh peak oil and any
of those things
uh
we have enough enough energy
uh for eight billion people that go
that's extends beyond extinction our
extinction will happen much sooner than
the exhaustion of energy okay that's my
argument on that
okay
takes a spider no one
[Laughter]
absolutely okay
see
eventually all humans will be replaced
by robots okay
i don't think we'll get to that point
that's my take on that
let me move on see if we have any
physics questions here
well uh
an object downwards acceleration free
fall about 9.8 meters per second square
that's weight and physics yeah that's
just all these people all they do is cut
and paste
uh you got to do a little more than cut
and paste you got to defend the
definitions you got to the arguments the
argument is that
mass is defined as quantity of matter
that's the notion people want to give
you but mass is also defined as weight
meaning the pressure it causes
on
a scale and so the question is what is
mass which of the two is it those are
two irreconcilable notions
and they like to use the one
uh for pressure on a scale because
that's the one
einstein used to say uh this this is
what mass is mass increases with the
speed of if as you approach the speed of
light that was his argument but that's
weight he's not talking about mass he's
talking about the pressure on a scale
he's not saying that the object is
gaining more atoms that's the point okay
and you got to attack that
all the rest just cut and paste that's
worthless nonsense okay
okay let's see what else we got here uh
yeah what object has no shape uh one
fall ass right and there's not an object
that you can imagine that has no shape
okay
and
and one file says many objects take the
shape of its container yeah but it has
shape
i don't care if it takes the shape of a
container uh
you know in case in fact uh the the
case i always give is
you have a balloon full of air okay
what is the shape of air inside the
balloon well let's say the balloon is
perfectly round fine so the shape of air
in that balloon that that blob there
it's round okay now we take that balloon
to outer space
okay uh astronaut takes it out there he
pops it okay let's assume he can do that
okay a special balloon okay so he pops
it now the air is coming out of there
every single atom that forms that blob
of air is there
okay if we could color-coded we could
see it and say okay here's the blob and
that blob is going to drift and form
into some irregular blob it's not going
to be spherical anymore i take a
snapshot at any point in time okay of
that blob expanding in a regular
shape through space that whole blob has
shape
you can turn in your in your grave you
can turn yourself upside down you can do
whatever you want that blob has shape
okay so that blob of air has shaped a
gas always has shaved it had better have
shape because it's made out of atoms
anything made out of atoms had better
have shape
okay it doesn't work the other way
around you can't say a concept has shape
okay because
there is it's not made out of atoms but
that's irrelevant the point is a a
concept is a relation between two
concepts that two objects and you can't
have a relation
in new of an object
very simple if you can't understand that
you got to go back to kindergarten guy
that's just that simple
okay uh father says
[Music]
what is the definition of word and the
word writing
i don't understand the question so i'm
going to have to take that as a uh i got
to think more about what the fellow is
asking if you can clarify that i'd
really appreciate it i'm not sure what
you mean word but the issue is
i'm just going to clarify something that
is maybe tangential to that and that's
we don't define every word in the
dictionary
to please the devil's advocate okay
extreme devil's advocate uh we say
object is that which has shape and they
say well what do you mean by shape
why don't you ask
what did you mean by that
what did you mean by which
what did you mean by those words i mean
is is the word which or the word that
are those easier to define
than the word shape
so what are we going to do spend all day
long defining those four words and then
people say well what did you mean by
those words that you use to define that
which has shape
you know we can spend
an eternity
and that's what science is about
the issue here is that you have to
define the word
object because that's what we're going
to be doing physics with you we're going
to do it with objects we can't do it
without objects and the problem right
now is that we have to attack
the definition of mathematical physics
what does mathematical physics have well
they have this notion that it's c and
touch
so that's what we have to destroy we
have to destroy the notion that an
object for the purposes of physics has
to do with see and touch
with an experiment with having two
objects somehow meeting you know the
touching
that's what we have we're against we're
saying all objects in the universe have
shape it's a universal property
all of
all objects and
that's a universal property and it
doesn't require an experiment it doesn't
require
two objects
with one object we've got it
and on the other hand here you have uh c
and touch
they are both verbs
you have to define nouns before verbs in
physics we have to have an object before
it can move and here we're saying oc and
touch which are actions
that's one issue another one is that you
need two objects
and then another one is that you know
again
you know it's a verb it's a dynamic
thing and you have to run an experiment
you have to wait till you know the guy
touches the moon before you can call you
know the asteroid touches the moon
before you can call either one an object
so is the asteroid not in the moon are
those objects before they touch each
other
i mean well while the
asteroid is traveling it hasn't hit the
moon yet so it's not an object because
it hasn't touched the moon
and if the blind man doesn't see it it's
not an object so this is the issue the
issue is we're pitting
shape against sea and touch
and what these people fall back on is
tradition
and they say well we have always done it
like this
or the majority of the world votes
for the seed touch that's what they use
go go find yourself another word
yeah because they realize that their
religion dies right there
if they can't use c touch they don't
have to use experiments and they say no
but science is about experiments well
what experiment are you gonna and what
what's c touch
what are you gonna see and touch when
you're doing gravity
what are you gonna touch what are you
going to see
the mediator is there no object there no
thing
even in quantum mechanics you have
particles in general relativity you have
the
four-dimensional space-time which is
treated as an object
and they say well you're weighing down
the canvas the fishnet and then they say
well disregard that though you don't
take it literally but that's how they
give their explanation their physical
interpretation so so they're treating it
as an object
they have to treat it as an object if
they're going to give you a physical
interpretation of a mechanism of gravity
that's how simple it is and so yeah they
you have to have an object and then when
you say well uh
we do it with ropes and they say well
why can't i see her touch him well
because again
here it is you know uh can you see your
touch
uh the whatever is coming in contact
with a pen when it falls downwards
why does it fall upwards nothing is
coming in contact with the skin of the
pen
is that what you're trying to tell me
you're doing it with spirits black magic
no you had better have
something
invisible intangible
that is in contact with the skin of the
pen only then can you explain gravity
in physics
in a rational way
very straightforward if you elude that
you are an irrational individual you're
doing math you're just giving a
description etc etc you're not giving me
a physical interpretation of why what
causes
this pen to fall to the center of the
earth so yeah again a lot of these
people just cut and paste and that that
doesn't give us anything but regarding
the uh word of word uh we don't define
any word in every word in the dictionary
i'm not sure what the context is here i
don't know how important
the word is
the word word is or the word what was
the other writing
i don't know uh
please clarify that uh and i'll take it
as an action item okay i'll read it
later okay if i wear a balloon in space
we get a sphere yeah flame is spherical
in space well i don't care i'm just
saying that uh what you have there there
is no such thing as a flame essentially
okay flame is a word we use to refer to
one of those things that we see in the
fire okay uh
depending on how you look at it you
could say that flame is an object but uh
depending on the context but the issue
with flame is that what you have is
combustion
that's what flame is that's what fire is
it's combustion it's a process
so fire is not a physical entity but the
physical entity is what's combusting
that's the physical entity you have to
identify okay something is being
oxidized
that's what
fire is okay so no there is no physical
object called fire we in ordinary speech
we point we say oh fire oh flame but in
in physics we can't use that or that
notion of ordinary speech
in physics we have to identify the
physical object and the physical object
in this case is oxygen whatever is being
oxidized okay that's the physical object
so please do not confuse
the fire with the
process of combustion
okay
what is a well i still don't understand
uh where is just standing for objects
words are yeah
words are
a concept that we use
to represent
uh
thoughts
and things you know when we when we look
at a word table we use the word table to
refer to
the thing we're pointing at it's just a
sound that we make
and in the case of writing we turn that
sound into some
phonetics you know some letters but
those are
representations of the sound we made
when we identified an object by pointing
that's all that a word is so i don't
know again what the context is there
what what the point of the question is
uh
please specify more detail
uh what you want you're look seeking
okay
as far as i can tell a word is just a
sound we make first
you know remember the indians and the
old people
of old the people of old previous
generations
they didn't even have writing in many
cultures they just made sounds and they
were able to communicate through sounds
maybe sound you know you even have uh
the
deaf mutes and they talk with their
hands okay
so words
it's just
a representation of the sound we make
by putting it in writing in such a way
that you know you can identify that
with the sound you made and you could be
referring to an object you pointed to
and that word uh could be also a concept
and you don't point to concepts you
define concepts so
that's all i can tell you okay
anyways he flamed his electromagnetic
light spectrum
okay with that i'll see you next time
and when is it sunday we'll see you then
bye bye